foreign
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
and it's pretty intense today with the
brilliant Professor Brian Greene he is a
theoretical physicist he is also the
director of Columbia University's Center
for theoretical physics he has gone very
deep into string theory and mere
Symmetry and so many things that I don't
really understand extremely well but I'm
super fascinated with I've always been
interested in the universe and our
reality and how everything works so we
talked about time we talked about
entropy we talked about Dimensions we
talked about matter and what we're made
of and we really just kind of drilled
down on some of the fundamentals that we
experience in life we talked about the
hydron collider in Switzerland in CERN
and what what the role of that is and
what they've learned from it and what
they're trying to learn Brian is a
professor and so he has an incredible
ability to be able to communicate in a
comprehensive way for me I love to learn
a little past my limit because that's
the only way you do learn you get those
words planted inside of you and then
they kind of are seeds and they grow so
I understood a lot but there's some
stuff I didn't understand I'm grateful
for that because that just means that I
will expand just like the universe enjoy
please hit subscribe button and the bell
for notifications I'd love to hear the
things that resonate with you in this
interview in the comments and just some
of your thoughts on it we all play a
part in this sort of zeitgeist of
information so um put your thoughts down
yeah I I'm super super excited about
this I uh Jen said before we started she
goes are you ready and I was like I'm as
ready as I'm ever going to be for a
theoretical physicist yeah it doesn't
take as much preparation as you think
we're a silly bunch
uh but it's like an incredible amount of
math right
there is if you're into the pushing the
boundaries of understanding side of it
which is of course the exciting thing
for a researcher to do but for the
general person who just wants the ideas
not interested in trying to make the
next breakthrough you don't really need
the math at all because all of this is
just a tool to understand things and
ultimately understanding can be
communicated in more ordinary familiar
language
so just through lecturing and reading
and watching things you're saying yeah
for sure I mean I know a gazillion
people who have a deep deep passion for
understanding everything from the
beginning of the universe to how Stars
work how black holes form you know what
the fundamental ingredients of matter
are
and they don't have any Math training
which means they can't get into the
details of how we figure things out but
sure I think anybody can grasp the idea
that
the universe is made of stuff and we've
tried to identify what that stuff is and
that stuff those particles they are
governed by certain laws we frame the
laws mathematically but in the end
they're just Rules of Engagement rules
of the road that the particles have to
abide by and from that we can build up
structures stars planets people and
we're off and running so yeah you don't
need the math you can get it through
books and lectures and Well Done
programs discussions debates okay so you
but you need the math to prove it so
that you can teach it right like the
math is necessary otherwise there
wouldn't be there wouldn't be the
lessons because there wouldn't be the
proof and then you'd just be making it
up that's a pretty important point
because some of the ideas of physics are
so out there unfamiliar that you might
think it's just sort of the ravings of a
bunch of idle Minds to say it politely
or maybe lunatics who are off you know
the deep end just intuiting and positing
and making stuff up and that's not at
all what it's about we have a rigorous
set of procedures that are couched in
the language of mathematics exactly as
you say and we follow those mathematical
procedures and we
allow them to take us to new ideas about
the world and then we go out and we test
those ideas right I mean Isaac Newton
wrote down some math that governs how
bodies move
and then people went out and tested the
math and saw do the bodies move along
the trajectories that the mathematics
predicts and they did
and that allowed us to go the next step
and the next step forward
but how valuable are the crazy ideas
because at any point in time a lot of
the most brilliant people were looked at
as being crazy like they had crazy ideas
and some of them were even you know I
think about someone like a Nikola Tesla
that you know just seems like they were
almost
ostracized or they were so unique in
their thinking that they were all alone
on an island so does it take the crazy
thoughts though to back into math to
really go to the next level and and also
where do those thoughts even where those
crazy thoughts even come from yeah well
you know the thing is in rough language
there are crazy thoughts and then there
are crazy thoughts
and and and knowing the difference
between them is very difficult I mean
there are some crazy thoughts which as
you say have pushed our understanding
forward
Tesla had crazy thoughts that ultimately
proved deeply insightful Albert Einstein
had a handful of crazy thoughts that
were deeply insightful ultimate pushes
forward but when you analyze their crazy
thoughts
you realize that they emerged from deep
and and systematic and and creative
thinking about some very specific
problems that they understood really
well because they'd already gone through
the Corpus of understanding that had led
up to their moment in history
there are other crazy thoughts that I
get all the time in emails and letters
Sometimes some phone calls which is the
most disturbing of all wow and and these
are from people who
I hold no ill will toward I really mean
that
but I get you know manuscripts from
people who say I've been in my basement
for 20 years and I finally figured it
all out and you get this thick
manuscript of all these ideas and
diagrams and equations and after sort of
30 seconds or a minute of looking at it
you realize there's nothing here but the
ravings of as kind of unhinged mind
maybe just unhinged in physics maybe
they're perfectly hinged in everyday
life I don't know but they've gone off
the deep end and I always feel
deeply sad for some of these individuals
because they did what you did in a sense
they said look at what Tesla did crazy
thoughts that changed the world look
what Einstein did crazy thoughts that
changed the world I'm gonna be the next
one I'm gonna come up with some crazy
thoughts and they're going to change the
world too and and maybe that will happen
one day but the the challenge is the
other individuals that were making
reference to and it's not just Tesla and
Einstein it's it's Faraday and it's
Maxwell and it's bore and it's
Heisenberg and it's true right so many
of them they all deeply studied
everything that was known to that point
and they put in the hard work the labor
to learn the mathematics to learn the
ideas that took us to the frontier of
understanding and with that Corpus of
knowledge they then went and allowed
their creative minds to go wild you
can't just let your creative mind go
wild when you don't have that kind of
rigorous training because it's not going
to lead anywhere for the most part so
there has to be there's a base you're
saying that the the
useful crazy ideas the the The Fringe
crazy ideas that send that can actually
turn into something that we use and we
understand and can be cutting edge
always usually starts with it usually
starts with a base of knowledge it comes
with them there's has to be some
information so then where is it I'm very
fascinated with
um
like where this information comes in and
it feels like a lot of really brilliant
people have an epiphany or a thought or
an idea a concept something that they
really are curious about and they
believe in very much and spend a lot of
their life backing into how that can
actually be put into a mathematical
equation so I'm curious where if you
believe that's true on some level and
where do those where does that come in
where do the where do those Concepts
come in and what I'm kind of leading
into is consciousness quantum
entanglement and the field around us
yeah so
the the short answer to that important
question is I don't know and nobody on
planet Earth does so it's a it's a great
question but but nobody really knows and
obviously as we head into the arena of
artificial intelligence that question
becomes ever more pointed and can be
explored in very specific ways I mean I
think you know I've certainly played
with some of the new AI systems and have
been in some cases pretty impressed with
what seems like creative ideas emerging
from A system that I do not believe is
conscious oh wow you know so that so
that that's a curious you know
combination right there but going back
to just the human
side of it you know I think what the
brain does what the brain does is
obviously it's a survival Gadget right
our brain evolved because our ancestors
in the African Savannah and elsewhere in
planet Earth they were under pressure
to to to find the next meal to to get
lodging that would protect them from the
harsh environment and you look at us
we're not the strongest out there in the
world we're not the fastest right what
do we have we have cognitive abilities
right that are among the most
sophisticated on planet Earth I'm not
going to say I don't like you know this
kind of human singularism human
exceptionalism per se there are other
intelligent creatures on the planet but
we're in the we're in the upper echelon
let's say relax sonar in a few things so
yeah that's right exactly and and so
what we did is in order to survive we
gained an Ever more refined capacity
through evolution by natural selection
to find Creative Solutions to the
challenges that we Face rather than you
know being able to jump over that
fast-moving stream we found a way of
navigating through that fast moving
stream that most other life forms
wouldn't have found and so we then
passed on this creative ability to
abstract and come up with Creative
Solutions we pass it on to the next
generation and they refined it and on
and on it went across the generations
and then when it comes to science
basically what is science science has
taken that capacity and pushing it well
beyond the needs of survival right we
don't need to understand electrons right
we don't need some electrons or quantum
physics or black holes to get the next
meal or or to have you know shelter but
what our brains do is they overshoot we
go beyond the needs of mere survival and
so that creative Instinct that served us
well in the ancestral world now gives us
the capacity to understand esoteric
qualities of the world like quantum
physics and entanglement and black holes
in general relativity and so forth so
somewhere in that evolutionary mix is
the answer to your question but if you
ask me when I look at some of the deep
insights of physics and look you know
one of my specializations is in
relativity so Einstein of course is the
grand hero so I'll just use him as an
example but there are many when I look
at some of the ideas that Einstein
introduced into physics like curved
space-time yeah I've tried to follow his
reasoning because I wanted to answer
your question where did this idea come
from yeah
trace it back and you can post facto
make an explanation aha he was thinking
about this then this then this and but I
think we're just making up a story I
think at some level the human brain
rearranges ingredients it finds new
patterns it finds new combinations and
Einstein had the ability to find a
radically new combination that nobody
had thought about before that ultimately
led to his greatest contribution the
general theory of relativity so
somewhere in that mix of a brain that
can creatively find Solutions
and just the wonderful architecture of
the mind that allows it to rearrange
pieces new ideas emerge there's a
thought that there's no UniQue Ideas no
new ideas is that do you believe that to
be true well it depends of course how
you defined Define the word new
um I think the vast majority of ideas
are rearrangements of existing pieces
you know finding new patterns within
stuff that's already out there and to my
mind if that teaches you something if it
gives you Insight if it allows you to
leverage it to build something that you
couldn't have done before then I'm happy
to call it a new idea so I guess I'm
maybe a little less strict with my
definition of new but from from that
perspective I'd say the ingredients are
there but it's all about how you arrange
them and the patterns that you find then
what are we if we're pattern making
machines if we're meaning making
machines right what what exactly are we
I have a couple of answers to that and
they all interleave at some level and I
think in addressing an important
question like that you have to choose
the level of analysis that you're asking
the questions so if you ask me what are
we at the fundamental physical level I'd
say we are nothing but large collections
of particles atoms electrons protons
neutrons that have configured themselves
into a very specific coherent pattern
that allows us to navigate the world in
the manner that we do so answer number
one where bags of particles governed by
physical law that's mostly energy right
so empty space too it's mostly empty
space and the particles carry energy and
there's certainly is energy in the form
of radiation that we are immersed within
so yes there's a wonderful interplay
between the stuff that we're made of and
the ambient environment I wouldn't want
to stop my explanation of who we are
there because it's very mechanistic and
so I would start to build up and if we
had enough time I'd go through a bit of
chemistry a bit of biology but let me go
right to the level of human mind because
that's really I think where we feel who
we are and at that level the language
that you used I would concur with we are
meaning making machines we are pattern
recognition devices we find it very
useful to look out into the world and
organize things as that helps us to
survive and to gain greater insight into
the kinds of behaviors that will be
beneficial to us and so we are bags of
particles that have the special ability
to find patterns to invent meaning and
in that way to experience the world at
the level that you and I are right now
at the conscious level that to me is
still a deep mystery
where does Consciousness come from but I
would say in between these two scales
bags of particles and meaning making
pattern recognition machines that sort
of spans the gamut of what we mean by a
human being do you agree with Elon Musk
that there's a very high probability
that we are a simulation it seems like
as pattern recognizers like and then we
we make these patterns essentially in
our world
that we're a pattern making a pattern
wouldn't a pattern make a pattern yes
and and there are many self-referential
versions of that statement you know we
are collections of atoms that can
contemplate atoms
we are massive
amounts of molecules that can make
meaning right I mean so there is this
wonderful juxtaposition between
our physical makeup the fact that
everything else in the world has its
physical makeup and we recognize that
because we are patterns of particles
with the capacity to find patterns in
other particles so I think it's a
beautiful a beautiful story about how
there's an objective world out there and
we can build a model of that objective
World in our subjective minds and that
allows us to navigate and and survive in
a way that would be difficult otherwise
as to the question though that you
started with with are we in a simulation
I would have to say from a gut feeling I
think I would like most people recoil at
that idea say the answer manifestly is
not true there are powerful arguments
and I don't know the one that Elon Musk
perhaps is making a reference to but
certainly you can imagine that
if in the future I don't believe that we
have this capacity at least here at the
moment but if we are able to build
artificial systems computers say that do
have sentience that do have an inner
world of conscious experience then yes I
think in the future it may be possible
to simulate worlds in which there are
beings inside the simulation yeah that
feel things right I don't I don't see an
obstacle to that in any fundamental way
I don't think I don't think that this
Gloppy gray biological thing inside of
our heads is essential to have the kinds
of experiences that we do I think if
there's a computational version of this
that does it correctly and that's a big
question how would you how would you do
that I don't see any obstacle for there
to be a feeling sensing being inside of
a computer I don't I don't see a
fundamental obstacle if that's the case
you do run into an interesting idea
which is in the very far future whatever
that means
it may be very easy to sit down in the
evening flip on a few switches
push a few buttons and create a whole
universe inside of a computer
and if everybody is doing this it's the
new fad you can imagine that there are a
gazillion of these simulated worlds
running in parallel on all these
computers and then you'd say well what's
the likelihood that this universe is not
one of the that this one is somehow
special it's a real Universe well I
think there's only one real Universe if
they're a gazillion simulated ones the
odds are we're in a simulation and
that's sort of the way that that
reasoning goes
um the big if can you create
Consciousness in a computer nobody
really knows the answer to that and the
other big if and this is emphasized by a
philosopher named Nick Bostrom at Oxford
just to give credit where credit is due
he said look maybe it's the case that
any sufficiently advanced civilization
that gains the capacity to understand
things well enough to make sentience
inside of a computer at the same time
they're also building sophisticated
weapons because apparently that that's
what smart beings do at least from this
one easy data and they blow themselves
up before they get to the point of
creating these simulated worlds maybe
nobody survives long enough because
we're such an aggressive yeah life form
um so that's the other way that you can
obviate this conclusion that we're in a
simulation or you can simply say hey I
don't believe that you'll ever have
Consciousness in a computer done end of
story I can see the pathway I mean if
there was something if Consciousness if
I was controlling if I was using a
controller and playing a video game then
I am
the Consciousness is still making that
player do something it is but it's still
channeled through you you know what we
what we think is a flesh and blood look
we've never met and right now you're
just a bunch of pixels on my screen but
I'm assuming that you're not some sort
of fancy video chat bot that there's a
real human being there uh and given that
you are still the initiator and the
origin of the Consciousness that's
driving your avatar in that video game
imagine though you don't need that that
the Avatar in the video game is so
sophisticated that it creates its own
conscience and maybe it can even
replicate within that world and have
children that are conscious sure but
doesn't it'll start it has to start I
mean that's where Google and all these
programs are collecting data and
creating an eye with it is that it does
start with us though so far so far I
agree that in the examples that we're
playing with now which are you know from
10 years to 100 years to A Thousand
Years are going to look so so incredibly
archaic and rudimentary
but but yes so right now we're having
these systems that are training on the
Corpus of text on the internet in books
that we human beings have created so and
since we are giving birth to these
systems their intelligence is emerging
from our intelligence but that is just
the beginning I think we've seen so
you've probably seen these wonderful
examples where a chess programs have
been written or for the in go have been
written and how do those chess programs
become expert well in the old days it
was you had a really smart person who
understood chess who would program them
how to play but now these chess programs
they battle against each other and
through winning and losing they refine
their own playing capacity there isn't a
human being saying hey you know Rook to
pawn seven or whatever I don't even know
what that means right I don't play chess
the system is learning from experience
and that's not human intervention human
set it up but then we can sip and let
the system and that's what's exciting
and terrifying at the same time so what
does what defines sentient then
tough question
I think it's the kind of thing we know
when we see it or more precisely we know
when we feel it feel it yeah I mean
inside my brain I have one example of
sentience it's my own
and I can try to describe it obviously
everything I say will be very familiar
to anybody else who has sentience you
know I can feel things I can imagine
things I can think about things in the
past I can conjure imagery in my mind I
can feel sad I can feel happy I can feel
later so all those things that we call
the qualities of a conscious being is
what we mean by sentience but the the
Paradox or the challenge perhaps is a
better word I I have no knowledge
that any other being a sentence and no
other being has any knowledge that I'm
truly sent in I could just be a really
sophisticated program and there's really
no way for you to know and so I'm
assuming that my kind of experience of
sentience resonates with yours but but
you may not even have any sentence you
may just be a shell of a person not in
there I don't think you are so don't
take this personally I don't have a lot
of feelings but I've just thought I have
some but you know it's just you can't
get inside somebody else's head
in your head how can you know yeah it's
almost like
um you know one of my favorite movies
when I was a kid growing up and it's no
wonder that I'm interested in this stuff
was contact yeah hearing the you know
science versus spirituality and and and
uh Jody Foster being asked if she can
prove that she loved her dad and you
can't so it's almost like maybe maybe
sentience is the ability to feel yeah
it's certainly part of it and you bring
up that movie and one of my favorite
lines of that film was I'll probably get
it wrong but when when Judah first Goes
Through the Wormhole and she's looking
at this beautiful
extraterrestrial world out there and she
says they should have sent a poet no
because you know that's that's the only
person who could really capture in in
human language the the Splendor the
Grandeur The Wonder of it all so yes
yeah the the capacity to be able to feel
but it's also a little bit further
because
you know if you have um I'm not saying
that a fly is in conscious there's some
level of Consciousness but there's a
difference I think between the level of
consciousness of a fly or an ant and
what we feel but but clearly you know if
you if you nudge an ant it moves in a
different direction it felt something
maybe it has some instinctual
repulsion against danger that has been
instilled in it through evolution by
natural selection what we can do is not
only feel
but we can feel that we feel
we can recognize that we can feel and
it's that self-referential capacity that
I think lifts us up and allows us to not
only
examine the external world but to look
back on ourselves and recognize that we
are examining the external world and
somewhere in that self-referential
capacity is the distinguishing
characteristic that that makes us us
yeah I I totally agree I am
often thinking about the fact that what
what makes us us what makes what is real
and what is a human and the fact that
we're able to and what is consciousness
and the fact that we're able to be aware
that we're aware awareness of thoughts
then it's not we're not the ocean then
in a way right we're not the ocean not
knowing it's the ocean we are aware
we're the ocean right no that that's the
key thing it's a key thing because you
can imagine a lot of systems that
respond to stimuli in the environment
and in some sense are feeling the
environment we obviously can do that but
we can look back on ourselves and
recognize that that's what we are doing
and it's that feeling and feeling that
we are feeling that allows us to
have a very different perspective on the
world one that allows us to distinguish
ourselves in a very clear sense from the
external environment so it makes me
think a little bit about time a little
bit about time travel and
I'm fascinated by it and and some of the
things as of late that I've done and I
describe them as time travel is like
EMDR
um some some therapists use their hand
but it's a rapid eye movement you go
left right left right either with a hand
or for me my therapist uses a buzzer so
there's a buzzer in each hand and it
goes back and forth and you go into a
memory and then from that memory you
just let your mind essentially go blank
as best as you can like it's like
meditation it's super hard but that's
what you need to do and then you're able
to revisit the experience from your
maturity level your experience level
seeing it from a from a Observer
standpoint seeing it from their
standpoint or someone else's standpoint
that was a part of this memory and I get
very curious as to whether or not we're
actually time traveling because that's
the way I would describe it
um I would it and so I wonder like what
what is time and then are we actually
able to time travel I also think about
sleep I think about psychedelic
experiences and in these spaces you have
these visceral real experiences and now
for sure at least with the MDR my memory
is completely reprogrammed from every
every event that I I went into yeah so
so
you know the language can be
[Music]
um
suggestive but also potentially
dangerous so I like to be slightly
precise in in the words that I use here
oftentimes when people talk about time
travel they mean it in a more literal
sense that you will leave wherever we
are today I don't even know what the
date is but call it June 6th or
something 2023 or something like that
whatever that we leave this date and we
may only age you know five minutes but
we go to
June 6 2090 or June 6 34 97 we actually
go to a different date or we go to a
different date in the past
and there are aspects of that that we
understand from the point of view of
physics and their aspects that we don't
briefly put Albert Einstein did lay down
a blueprint for in principle underscore
in principle how to go arbitrarily far
into the future in this flat-footed most
literal sense okay go near the speed of
light your clock ticks off time at a
different rate that allows you to go
into the future or you hang out near the
edge of a black hole your clock ticks at
a different rate that allows you to go
into the future we haven't done this we
don't know how to travel near the speed
of light we've never gone near a black
hole those are details from the point of
view of fundamental physics traveling to
the future we understand well to the
past is another story that we could
describe most of us don't think it's
possible the time travel that you're
talking about is a version of time
travel but very different from the
literal one that I'm referring to here
and in many ways it's richer because
what you're referring to is the capacity
of our brains to revisit moments in the
past or to imagine moments in the future
and to engage with those periods in time
as if they were real as if is important
here you're not truly going to that past
moment you're not truly going
but you nevertheless are engaging with
it in a meaningful and and maybe helpful
maybe therapeutic way and that again
shows how powerful the human mind is I
don't think that the mind of an ant
is really going and imagining oh I
remember two years ago when Mama Ann you
know took me to the fair I don't think
the answer doing that right and and we
have the ability to do that and as
you're saying there are therapeutic
methodologies whereby we can even
modify our engagement with that past
event and people of course have used
these techniques for you know PTSD you
know to alleviate the symptoms and so
this is all really powerful and potent
stuff but it is different from the
literal version of time travel that we
have a pretty good handle on from the
standpoint of physics that doesn't mean
that it's less important in many ways
it's more important but it's good to
keep them separate yes totally accurate
Fair understand but it almost plays into
like the two examples of what are we
yeah there's the physical
and then there's the mental
totally
think about how to physically time
travel
but it feels like we've figured out how
to mentally time travel 100 and and and
I think that again just emphasizes The
Wonder of Consciousness The Wonder of
Consciousness is yes even if our
physical form is Tethered to the moment
we're not going to travel near the speed
of light tomorrow we're not going to go
near a black hole tomorrow so for the
practical purposes we are Tethered to
the moment but our minds are untethered
from the moment in a very powerful way
our minds are free to roam the timeline
yeah and that's wonderful and amazing
and just as a richness to our inner
World our inner experience our conscious
experience that our physical form is
unable to keep up with but that's the
the power and beauty of the mind yeah
well maybe that's where AI comes in well
yeah the AI is um is um is a very uh a
potent powerful and and frightening and
um exciting realm that we're now clearly
about to enter into and uh who knows
where it will lead and again the um the
the part of it that people never fully
grasp
it's really hard to get it across and I
sort of had hoped that the pandemic
would do this but it seems to not I mean
what happened in the pandemic was we saw
exponential growth which means only
three people are sick on Tuesday and
then you know half a million are sick
you know the following week and and what
exponential growth is
it's it's a process whereby when you
notice it it's too late to do much about
it because it's taken off you need to
anticipate it and so like when the
pandemic was just starting to Bubble Up
I was like okay I know what I saw what
was happening at least you know from the
standpoint of my family I did all I
could to prepare well before anybody was
worried about anything happening
similarly with AI it's gonna explode and
it's exploding at an exponential rate
and you need to deal with it now before
there are big problems that are staring
in the face or beating you down or
defeating you and I'm I'm I'm I'm glad
to see that people are recognizing this
at an early stage because once AI begins
to reinvent itself because that's the
power of this approach like with the
chess program that we mentioned before
AI can itself improve
doesn't need us if it's set up in the
right way and it's in essence doing
evolution by natural selection but not
on the time scales that physical systems
need which is millions and billions of
years in order to evolve because the
Generation by generation mutation by
mutation AI it can mutate in a
nanosecond and a nanosecond again and so
it's really important that we Face these
issues these important issues now yeah
well I mean that's somewhat been my
experience through psychedelics too is
that there's so much information in that
field that it makes it's no wonder why
we have to evolve slowly is because it's
too much data like it's overwhelming how
much information is in that space so
what have you done in psychedelics if
you don't mind sharing yeah um most of
most most things
um uh Ayahuasca
um how was that
Ayahuasca
um
it's it's a more aggressive
yeah yep one night got sick one night
didn't
um and but it was I mean it gave me a
very fundamental lesson in my life that
I needed to know yeah that took and has
been integrating for years and figuring
it out
um it feels like a bigger lesson in your
life like about your you yourself
um psilocybin is far more I've done
therapeutically as well as more
recreationally yeah um that to me is
understanding the universe to me that's
where you get a lot more information
about the field about how things work
um that feels very like
uh Planet oriented or Universe oriented
maybe maybe you should try that one well
well I I had one slightly rough
experience that has made me gun shy
about anything but people who I've
spoken to and I'm sure you would confirm
it that set and setting you know being
with the right people being with the
right guy can really make all the
difference in the world so at some point
I may uh I may try again because
obviously you know when I hear you and I
hear others describe being in the world
in a different way under the influence
of you know a certain chemical that to
me is really exciting because
Consciousness is all we ever experience
and if you can modify that experience in
an interesting and productive and
mind-altering way that that seems
important and and deeply compelling to
me the the little experience I had
though was so terrifying that it was the
kind of thing that was like
no one ever go back there again what
happened well it was you know I don't
want to go into any great detail um sort
of spoken about it elsewhere but um yeah
I think largely if I was going to say it
in one sentence
I could not let go
and if you can't let go or at least you
fight to not let go you're in a real
rough situation because your mind wants
to go far and explore and if you're
desperately hanging on every moment for
dear life it can be a real deep tension
between 100 and that's pretty much what
I what I experienced The Experience
isn't nearly as deep and or as
interesting too because the mind can
totally hold you back from going there
and it can be scary and it can be
uncomfortable yeah um yeah that's fair I
never would I never tell people you have
to do this I would only hope my
experience and
um like I hope any good Steward of that
of of psychedelics would say that it has
to call you it has to be something and
you do this do you do this on a regular
basis kind of thing or is it just as as
needed it's as it calls you know um
Ayahuasca was three years ago
my psilocybin Journey that I did was
like six months ago so but those have
been the most significant things other
than a little bit where did you do
Ayahuasca out of the country yeah Peru
yeah Peru yeah yeah yeah
um that kind of leads me into thinking
about
um Dimensions actually one thing I
forget you were talking about um
everything accelerating and there's a
theory within at least the spiritual
Community or like spiritual thoughts
that time is speeding up is there any
way that's possible
well I can talk directly from the
physics of the situation and I would say
there is resonance and that time is much
more fluid than we would think based on
everyday experience right everyday
experience seems to suggest that you're
watching my watch and everybody's watch
if it's a properly functioning watch
they're all taking tough time at the
same rate that's so all there is to it
and from a practical standpoint that's
pretty much true which is why it's what
we experience but from a physics
standpoint it's absolutely not true
because as I made reference to before if
you and I are moving relative to each
other our watches are not taking up time
at the same rate
um if I go to the top of a tall building
even on planet Earth my watch will be
taking off time a little bit more
quickly than clocks that are down on the
surface because I'm experiencing less
gravity and the less gravity you
experience the more quickly your clock
will tick compared to a clock that's
experiencing more gravity so in that
sense time speeds up it slows down
depending upon the gravity you
experience and the speed with which you
are moving but on planet Earth most of
us are pretty much moving at the same
speed yeah the only speed that matters
in this context is the speed of light
light travels so quickly that it's well
beyond any experience it goes 300
million meters per second it can go
around the entire Earth more than seven
times in one second
seven times around the Earth in one
second now if you can achieve those
speeds then the difference in your watch
and my watch would become manifest we
would see we would measure the
difference between those but on planet
Earth how fast do you go 100 miles an
hour
240 miles an hour like did I age more or
less going 240 miles an hour that's
right it's so it's so tiny we're talking
in the billions and the trillionths of a
second difference that it's irrelevant
from a practical standpoint so from a
practical perspective no time is not
spinning up it's not slowing down it is
the same for all of us on planet Earth
from a cosmic and I don't mean like new
agey cosmic I mean from the cosmic
perspective of how time behaves in the
universe there is no universal clock
there is no one time that we are all
Tethered to clocked tick off time
depending on how they move and the
gravity they experience
you do you remember an Interstellar yeah
I love that's my favorite movie oh good
so do you remember when um the Matthew
McConaughey and and the other
um uh actor I can't remember her name
sorry apologize yeah Anne Hathaway
exactly
go down that planet right and and there
are other uh companion back on the ship
I forget his name yep when they return
they were down there for like four hours
and he's aged 23 years yes okay this is
how science actually works that was not
Hollywood nonsense if you go near a
black hole the gravity is powerful that
slows the ticking of time on your watch
compared to the watch that's on the ship
far away from the black hole and so a
few hours for you on that planet near
the black hole would be something like
23 years for someone back on the ship
there you have time speeding up slowing
down right there and that that's
accurate yeah so that is it's real it's
just so minuscule here but it's real
it's just and this is how numbers this
is how scientists and physicists are
able to make calculations is that you
look at the small to get the big right
exactly that was that was the power of
Einstein you put your finger right on it
he would see a little crack in the
mathematics that wouldn't be relevant
for experience here on planet Earth but
he would push the mathematics forward
and reveal what that crack in her
understanding would mean through the
entirety of the cosmos and indeed he was
the one that found that time ticks off
at different rates depending on the
gravitational field so as time Dimension
that exists in the entire universe I
think so I think that's a reasonable way
of putting it it perhaps is less
mysterious than it might sound I mean
when we talk about Dimension It's
usually the data necessary to specify
where or when something takes place so
you know for us to have our conversation
I got a little email saying you know
it's going to be whatever 11 o'clock on
whatever is today Tuesday or something
is it you know 11 o'clock on Tuesday and
I needed to be you know at my desk to do
that right so what are the data you need
to give me some spatial data right I
needed to be you know here we also
needed to give a temporal piece of data
and that was the time and so three
pieces of data delineate where you are
in space one piece of data tells you
where you are in time so that's why we
say four dimensions not anything sort of
more mysterious than that and that's
relevant for events that are taking
place throughout the entirety of the
universe if you want to specify them you
have to say where they take place like
an X Y and Z coordinate a street an
Avenue and a floor number and then
you'll also have to say when they take
place there's your temporal Dimension
four pieces of data to specify events
so what are what are the dimensions
beyond that and how many dimensions are
we are we how many dimensions can we
prove I don't know so there may not be
any beyond that that's the most
flat-footed straightforward
interpretation of of the data but if you
ask somebody like me who spent decades
investigating the extra dimensional
possibility yeah there is interesting
Reasons from the math for taking the
idea of other dimensions at least
seriously we have not seen any evidence
I just need to be straight out about
that for these extra Dimensions but you
know for the past 35 years I've been
investigating theories that suggest that
there are more dimensions of space than
the three that we know about and why
where does this come from well we've
been trying to push forward to realize a
dream articulated initially by Einstein
of having What's called the unified
theory one mathematical theory that
would describe the big things in the
universe the Small Things in everything
in between and that's quite a challenge
Einstein himself never found this
unified theory but in the last few
decades we think we might again I need
to underscore there is uncertainty here
we think we might have that theory and
within that theory when we study the
math it says that the three dimensions
of space that we know about are not the
only ones
it says that there are at least six
probably seven depending on how you
formulated extra dimensions of space
that we've never seen But six or seven
beyond the four yeah okay yeah grand
total of 11 if you if you want to frame
it in that way and we have ideas
Regarding why we've not seen these extra
Dimensions one possibility is they're
they're not big like the dimensions that
we see around us they may be tightly
curled up into a very small shape and
they would be all around us but
just too tiny for us to easily see you
know I can give you you know I don't
know if I can yeah look at this so look
at this this little wire right yeah now
from far away you wouldn't be easy to
see the thickness you'd only see the
length of the wire sure but now as I get
closer and closer it becomes easier and
easier for you to see that there's an
extra Dimension a curled up circular
Dimension that goes around the wire it
doesn't just have length it also has
this circular part A curled up Dimension
imagine that circular part was
incredibly tiny
atomic scale then you wouldn't be able
to see it with a naked eye at all and
all it would look like is one line from
my left hand to my right hand
but if you zoom in
then the circular Dimension becomes more
apparent we think that might be true of
the universe this obvious Dimension
would be like left right back forth up
down three dimensions easy to see the
curled up part might be like those other
seven dimensions that are harder to see
they're all around us but so tiny that
the naked eye are even powerful
equipment that we currently have can't
access them what are we thinking or what
are you guys thinking is in the
dimensions well
everything that you know about in a
sense would be there because everything
fundamentally we learn from quantum
physics is vibrating Fields vibrating
fields of energy the electron feel the
Quark Fields gravitation is described by
a field and these fields can penetrate
these extra Dimensions if they have
adequate energy if they're strong enough
the fields are strong enough so in
principle anything can can probe into
those extra Dimensions it's just a
question of the amount of energy that
the the probe has
so there's a thought that like as we
grow and evolve our frequency goes up
and then maybe we could get into these
other dimensions or maybe this is just
access through that what that language
worries me a lot yeah it's because it's
because it's uh it's because it's mine
it's not a physicist language yeah but
let me let me just say why because I
mentioned earlier how often I get these
letters from people who are
investigating stuff and and a frequent
quality of those letters are things that
seem to resonate with what you're saying
they say to me you know Professor Green
you wrote about extra dimensions of
space I need to tell you I had an
experience of those extra Dimensions you
know I did this and I penetrated I
walked around yeah and I read that I'm
like oh my God please you know you you
you you're talking nonsense and and and
and and I again I don't mean that in a
derogatory way I just feel bad when
people go down directions that lead them
into places that we never meant these
ideas to go so we human beings were big
on the scale of these extra Dimensions
we big
clunky objects really don't have any
means of penetrating into these extra
Dimensions we don't have adequate energy
that is directed at a sufficiently small
size to do that so for all intents and
purposes
our brains our minds our bodies do not
penetrate into these extra Dimensions if
they are there the only way that we as
human beings would be able to access
these Dimensions is let's say with the
Large Hadron Collider in Geneva
Switzerland slamming protons against
protons at high energy and if we do that
the right way there's a chance we might
be able to probe the extra Dimensions if
the scales and the energies are correct
but it's never going to be that like the
human brain wafted into the extra
Dimensions or that our energy feel
wafted that kind of idea is is not part
of realities we understand it
what about the Hydra I I was actually
going to ask you about that what have we
actually learned from it enormous amount
enormous amount I mean the first big
Discovery was now a while ago I remember
I spoke about it in July 4th of 2012. it
was you know Independence Day I was in
Aspen Colorado at a big conference when
the Higgs boson was finally confirmed
this hypothetical this is actually
resonating with what we're talking about
before the math told a guy named Peter
Higgs as well as a number of others who
should get and do get credit but let me
just focus on him because his name is
the name of the particle the math showed
Peter Higgs that there should be a
particle of matter that we'd never seen
not an electron not a quark not a
neutrino but this
spinless boson as it's called called the
Higgs boson details don't matter but the
math predicted it
and then that was like in the 60s 2012
finally the Large Hadron Collider slams
protons together and produces this
little particle for the first time
spectacular right it's beautiful
um so that was then and since then the
the the the collider has allowed us to
refine our understanding of particle
physics enormously but it's not yielded
any revolutionary surprises yet and you
can read that two ways you can say well
wow so our theories are so good that
this machine is just confirming them
over and over again you know we should
you know slap ourselves on the back it's
an expensive uh theoretical physicist
that is that's right so so the other
view is we we need something new in
order to tell us what next direction to
go and so that that may require the next
machine a bigger machine more powerful
machine they are being designed and
developed we hope that they will be
built and those other machines when they
slam things together with even greater
force might probe the extra Dimensions
directly or produce a particle that is
completely unexpected or reveal a force
of nature that we had never even
imagined so that's the excitement but
also
sometimes the the the the the downfall
of our Insight is that the theories are
pretty good and it takes a lot therefore
to surprise us yeah yeah that is kind of
an amazing thought yeah
um are there any you know given the fact
that you're looking at hard numbers and
you're looking at the physics of how
everything works
is there some kind of ripple effect of
the amount of energy that the collider
is producing
that ripples out into the universe or
even the planet or the city that it's in
is there any I mean is that quantifiable
it is but it's it's it's trivially small
on the scales that we're talking about
yeah because when we talk about this
being a powerful powerful
collider what you have to really think
about is we're taking energy and we're
able to pinpoint it direct it into a
really small space that's what these
collisions are but just to give you a
sense of the energy scale the energy
scale
in that collider if you translated it
into uh how much mass you know are we
talking about energy and mass are the
same thing Einstein taught us and I
think it's easier for us to think about
Mass like so how much does that matter
though energy and mass does not matter
though well matter is one version of
energy it's not the only version there's
also radiation which is another version
of energy and we understand well the
interplay between them but in some sense
energy is sort of the Uber currency that
can then manifest you know in dollars or
Euros in matter or radiation sort of the
sort of way of thinking about it but but
matter if you will that we're able to
muster in these collisions is a tiny
fraction of of a gram like 10 to the
minus you know 10 grams or 10 times 15
grand it's minuscule on on everyday
scales it's huge on the scales of being
able to direct it into such a small
space
but but in terms of the ripple effect
it's just too modest really affect
anything at all why is it so big
well the energy that you create in a
collider is in some sense proportional
to the size of the collider because you
have to rev up these tiny particles that
weigh nearly nothing right
you have to rev them up to get them so
close to the speed of light so you need
a big race track to be able to do that
you rev them up and then you slam them
together and the bigger the race track
the easier it is to get them to the high
speed the high energy but again because
it's a proton
the impact on the outside world is Tiny
even if it's a highly energetic proton
is there is it able to
um Collide anything larger
um the Large Hadron Collider is not
directly set up to do that but there are
other machines for instance there's a
machine called The relativistic Heavy
ion collider which is not far from here
in New York and
those machines slam together heavier
nuclei where it's not just a single
proton it's groups of protons so yes we
can do that and you design the machine
based on what it is that you want to
study if you want to study fundamental
physics you want the simplest probe if
you have a complex probe there's a lot
of murky physics that comes you know if
you slam you know two BMWs together it's
a total mess how would you ever figure
out the details of what happened but you
slam two clean protons together much
easier to measure much easier to
determine what happened right right
um I another area of physics that is
interesting to me is um entropy and
um
does everything in the universe have to
have balance is there a is there a
universal law of
of of equal and opposite forces no there
isn't in many situations you will find
that so for instance if you look at a
planet like the Earth it's got a whole
lot of positive charges a lot of protons
making up the Earth but there's
basically the same number of negative
charges electrons so they all kind of
balance out and aggregate the Earth is
roughly speaking neutral in terms of its
charge and that's with us human bodies
as well you don't have to have that
though you could have imagined a world
where they're only positive charges or
only negative charges now things
wouldn't stick together so it'd be hard
to have Aggregates because like charges
repel each other that's why it's nice to
have balance because they can sort of
come together but I wouldn't say that
there's some overarching meta law of
reality that says that there has to be
some balance but in our world especially
when
getting to entropy the word that you
mentioned when it comes to a thermal
equilibrium we call it when things have
enough time to relax to their most
comfortable State balance will typically
happen electrons and their anti-particle
positrons they've got the same mass and
mass determines the amount of energy
needed to create those particles and so
if it's the same mass it's the same
energy necessary on average you'll
expect to have as many positrons as
electrons because of that so in practice
there's a lot of balance in the world
but nothing absolutely demands it and
I'll give you one key example
our world does not have a balance
between
matter and antimatter there are certain
examples where you will find them
certain systems like I mentioned with
electrons and positrons but take the
universe as a whole if there was a
balance of matter and antimatter well an
anti-matter and matter come together
they annihilate there'd be nothing left
we wouldn't be here and so there had to
be a little bit of an imbalance in the
amount of matter versus antimatter in
the early universe and not big you
needed one more particle of matter and
every billion particles of matter and
antimatter together just you needed a
billion and one of the matter against a
billion of the antimatter they
annihilate leaving one per billion and
that's enough to make you and me and
everything else right right we just need
now some time or whatever that is yes
you needed some imbalance so imbalance
is important in certain circumstances
without it we wouldn't be here right
well I think about well okay let me ask
the universe is expanding correct that's
and it's expanding
faster and faster yes
but
entropy is another fundamental truth in
the universe correct like yes everything
is essentially leading towards entropy
but yet it's the universe is growing at
an exponential rate so how does that how
how do you Rectify that or do those even
do those even go together as a thought
of how does that happen
they do it's a very intricate dance
between the entropy of the cosmos and
the size and the expansion of the cosmos
at some level you can imagine that there
is nice resonance because
if you think about entropy as disorder
you say to yourself well if a system is
bigger it has greater capacity to be
disordered right I mean if you have a
one bedroom apartment there's just so
much disorder there can be but now if
you've got 10 bedrooms you could have
disorder in all of them you could have
more disorder because you've got more
space
and so you might say the expanding
universe is compatible with an increase
in entropy because now there's more
space to house the increasing disorder
and there's some there's some truth to
it of that way of thinking it's not the
full story but certainly part of the
story but the interesting thing with the
accelerated expansion
is that in a way that would be a little
hard for me to explain fully but I'll
just give the basic idea because the
universe is expanding it faster than the
speed of light that's a crazy idea but
it is it means that there are places out
there Beyond which we can't see because
it once the expansion goes faster than
the speed of light the light can't reach
us
right so in a sense we are surrounded by
a sphere that we can't see beyond and
that's fear in some sense has entropy
and that entropy in that sphere is
generating some heat within our universe
so when you think about the far future
of the universe and what its entropy
will be like that's the situation that
you wind up analyzing imagining that we
are surrounded by a large sphere that's
coming from The Accelerated expansion
and that sphere itself has a temperature
and that temperature controls the final
entropy of the cosmos
it's a complex set of ideas but that's
how it works
yeah yeah that's um and very interesting
I don't completely understand that but
um I wouldn't expect as I said there's a
lot there's a lot behind every step in
there but yes there is a deep
relationship between the expansion of
the universe the temperature of the
universe the disorder or the entropy of
the universe they all play off each
other one of the thoughts I had growing
up as a kid the idea that it goes on for
Infinity because look up at the stars
and I would be like wow and then at the
end it doesn't end it's Infinity is that
true and can we even know that based on
what you just said about not being able
to see beyond the speed of light so does
it end you know we don't know and my
guess is if you were to interview a
whole or sample
a whole variety of physicists and
astronomers and astrophysicists I think
the dominant answer you would get is
that yes it goes on infinitely far
but we don't know that and it need not
go on infinitely far for instance the
universe could have a shape that is more
like the surface of the Earth right on
the surface of the Earth you walk in one
direction if you never change direction
you will return to your starting point
the surface is not going infinitely far
it could be the case in the cosmos that
you go out into space don't change your
direction you come back ultimately to
your starting point that's a possibility
too sure and then the expansion is just
essentially the planet growing that's
right it's making that surface or that
shape get larger you're absolutely right
and so so we don't know
and it does matter I mean there's
certain key ideas about the universe
that depend on this idea for instance if
the universe is not infinite then the
picture that we often paint when we talk
about the Big Bang we say in the past
the universe is smaller and smaller and
smaller and we say at the very beginning
it was like a little dot that then
erupted in this rapid swelling called
The Big Bang but you see the idea of
there being a DOT universe is completely
dependent on the shape of the universe
the size being finite because if it's
infinite let's say it really does go on
forever like your younger self imagined
when you're out there looking in the
Stars it goes on Heavenly far let's say
you go back in times that the universe
is half its current size well what's
half of infinity infinity
so it's always infinite even at the Big
Bang it's infinite so this idea of a
little Dot from which we all came that's
a misnomer if the universe is infinite
then it was infinite even at time zero
and the whole thing erupted and started
to expand from the infinitely dense
state of the infinite expanse at the
beginning of time itself so it really
changed our picture huh yeah because of
course when you say it's it's expanding
you're implying that there's an end
not necessarily because that's why you
have to change the shape so so so
imagine it is the infinite Case by
expansion it's not that we are
encroaching on new space that wasn't
already included it's simply that the
distances between points in the existing
space are growing larger so imagine you
have like an infinitely big piece of
rubber it can still
even if it's not encompassing new space
I see it's spreading out spreading out
exactly ah so
right and we probably don't have the
technology to know if there are
we're discovering new galaxies and
universes if we're galaxies and we don't
we're not necessarily but they're being
born right but they're also dying but
look all we can ever do is gather light
through powerful telescopes right we
have the James Webb Space Telescope
maybe heard of it it's out there right
now a million miles from Earth making
these stunning pictures but what is it
it's a big mirror that gathers light so
all we can ever do is gather radiation
gather light in various wavelengths or
gather gravity in various wavelengths
and so forth I will beginning to do in
the future
we can't see things that are Beyond a
certain distance they're just too far
away for the light to have ever reached
us and the light may never reach us and
therefore if there's an end out there it
may be beyond what we can see if it goes
on infinitely far that's certainly
beyond what we will ever be able to see
so this may be a permanently unanswered
question
what what do you think it would mean to
actually figure out
The Theory of Everything to be able to
relate the small to the big for
everything in the universe what would
that what would that mean for us well
you know for people like me it would
mean that retirement
that's a whole nother question but um
for me it would mean that the human mind
had risen to the challenge
of grasping the fundamental laws of the
cosmos
so that's not a very practical answer
but it is one that I think would fill me
and my colleagues with a sense of
how amazing is it that we were
constructed in just the right way to be
able to grasp the fundamental truth the
fundamental laws and that would be
thrilling and wondrous but from a
practical standpoint what would it mean
it's hard to say I will say this though
if you and I were to have this
conversation in the 1920s 100 years ago
at that time the big thing was quantum
physics and if you said to me hey you
guys are developing this quantum physics
about atoms and molecules like if it's
right what will that mean at that point
I probably would have said something
similar won't mean much it'll mean that
we can understand blah blah blah some
some of what I said a moment ago but now
you fast forward till today and the fact
that you and I are having this
conversation is relying on quantum
physics because the integrated circuit
which is in all of our computers and all
of our devices would not exist without
quantum physics quantum physics allowed
us to guide the motion of little
particles these little electrons so
these miniature circuits allowing us to
have the whole electronics Industry
emerge and explode which is all just to
say that it's often hard to predict
where fundamental Discovery will lead in
1920s nobody could have imagined the
iPhone or the personal computer but
their work led to it if we figure out
the final ultimate unified theory yeah
who knows where it will go
do you think that
us as human beings and our programming
or whatever it is that makes us up is
really even capable of being able to
um make these kinds of discoveries do
you think that it's perhaps inherent to
our nature that we aren't going to get
all the answers
I don't know and if it is the case I
wouldn't say it's because there's some
Divine decree where some super
intelligence some divine plan said let's
let the humans go this far and no
further or something like that again I
just think that we emerge through the
blind forces of evolution by natural
selection we have this capacity to find
patterns as we started our conversation
in our discussion and in those patterns
we've been able to gain insight into how
things work now is this thing
sufficiently developed to be able to
answer every question that we encounter
some might say well the questions are
coming from in here so maybe this thing
is well suited to the very questions
that is able to come up with or the
questions you they are well they're more
fundamental no no they're coming from
out there and why should this inner
structure have the capacity to answer
every question at the external world and
conjure and I think the real answer is
we'll keep going we'll push forward
maybe one day we'll hit a wall and we'll
be unable to answer anything else we'll
go to the beach we'll enjoy ourselves
Daiquiri whatever but maybe we will
continue to make progress and as long as
we can we will push forward
one of the experiences in psilocybin was
that it felt like I went to a baseline
reality which was a waveform and in that
space I immediately went how am I ever
going to be human I know it's not real
so
it makes me wonder
what is it that creates our reality then
yeah I mean I think we create our own
reality and don't take that the wrong
way I do think there are real things in
the world I mean there is this real cop
you know while you know there's real
stuff but the way we organize that stuff
and the way we assign meaning to that
stuff and value to that stuff is all
something that we invent inside of our
heads right and so that's the way in
which we create narratives and stories
in order to be able to understand our
world and to feel good about our world
to get us up in the morning and to try
to do things we tell ourselves story
that's important to do that but there is
no Cosmic importance there's no
fundamental importance the universe
doesn't give a hood whether we do X Y or
Z we really just need to be having a lot
more fun then well it's all invented
it's all invented so we invent the
things that we consider to be important
and then we pursue them as best as as we
can
and that is a fruitful way of being in
the world but there are other ways of
being in the world and who knows maybe
we will find a different way of
organizing and and navigating maybe
through psychedelics maybe through
something completely different AR via
maybe we'll be in the meta version I
don't know but the point is it is all
invented in the sense of without
invention all you've got are particles
governed by forces loading through the
void that's it was there not
something that just happened where
I'm gonna probably get the words wrong
um proving like non-locality for things
like a table that that unless it's
observed it's not there
um I wouldn't agree with the very last
part of your description but certainly
with the entanglement ideas you you may
be referring to the fact that this
year's Nobel Prize right went to three
physicists John clauser Anton's Islander
and uh Alanis Bay for work that they
pioneered over decades establishing that
quantum physics does have this so-called
non-local property which is you can have
a particle here and a particle there
can really be arbitrarily far apart but
if you set things up in the right way
when you do something to this particle
it instantaneously affects or at least
is correlated with the behavior of this
particle as if they were right next to
each other and yet they're not is that
also quantum entanglement as well it is
quantum entanglement yeah and this is an
idea that Einstein was one of the early
investigators spooky things happening at
a distance yes exactly and that language
really showed clear that Einstein did
not like this idea did not think it
could possibly be true and in fact in
the 1935 paper that Einstein wrote with
his colleagues Podolski and Rosen his
point was
hello Quantum physicists look at what
your theory is predicting distant
objects behaving as there are one I'm
gonna shake you out of your Quantum
stupor you Quantum physicist that was
his perspective he didn't think it was
real and now we know it's real because
the experiments have established this
quality and now not only are Nobel Prize
is being awarded for it but it's the
basis of what's known as the quantum
computer which is a computer that makes
use of these strange connections to do
calculations much more quickly than it
otherwise would be able do you think
it's possible that as we continue to
learn and grow and evolve and collect
more information that essentially we
create new math over and over again to
be able to
establish an understanding totally
totally I mean you know the work that I
was fortunate to be involved with some
years ago
in a part of string theory that yielded
insights into mathematics required that
we develop new mathematics to understand
what it was that we were describing so I
had a wonderfully productive
few months years and years ago at the
institute for advanced study in
Princeton which is where Einstein was
for the last couple decades of his life
but I was there much later obviously and
I worked with a mathematician a guy
named David Morrison he's at University
of California Santa Barbara now and we
would spend hours and hours a day where
I would teach him physics he would teach
me mathematics because we knew that what
we were working on required us each to
know the language of the other really
well so we could blend it together and
create Quantum mathematics in order to
fully understand what it is that we were
working on for sure and many others I
don't mean to make it sound like I'm the
only one who done this there are many in
the field who have
revolutionized mathematics from the
physical understanding of a citizen is
quantum mathematics quantum physics and
put into math is that is that done is
that all understood or is that still
unfinished to a large degree very much
unfinished and I think we really only
caught the the glimpse of what it's all
about and whether it's a year or a
decade or a century away from completion
I don't know but it's a very exciting
time because again many of my colleagues
are pushing the frontier more than I am
at the moment but there's such deep
insight to nature of space and time and
Quantum accounts in black holes it's all
going to reinvent our understanding of
the physics and we will require a
mathematical language to accurately
encapsulate all that which is very much
a work in progress What discovery could
be made that would make that would
change our reality the most well I think
if we truly understood How the Universe
began all we have is a description of
how it evolved we don't really know how
it got started I think that's the real
big one and connected with that is the
issue of what truly is time you ask
before is it another dimension a nod in
my head and sort of explained the way in
which it gives us the fourth piece of
data so you know where and when an event
took place but if you ask me okay fine
but what is time but really is it I
would Mumble things like well it's what
allows for change to occur or you know
it's what allows everything to not
happen all at once or something like
that but the truth is nobody really
knows what time is and I think having a
deep understanding of that abstract idea
is a is a very important and potent
question going forward thank you so much
yeah see we're right on time whatever
this time thing is we are right on time
excellent well anyway it was great
talking to you thank you so much
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the Subscribe button